don't make as much money as my Bros and
we've got a bachelor party coming up
that's pretty pricey just for me it
seems do I skip it or ask the best man
if I could pay less here's what you do
bro
you cruise into daylight not only have
you had to drink less at this point it
is a veteran move right now everyone
goes too hard the first night everyone
blows their load the first night then
you Cruise in night two good energy the
Bros get fired up on that you don't have
to pay for the activities they did on
night number one or whatever the crap
was because then you're only doing night
two and then you know night three you go
home it's a three-day bachelor party you
guys are psychos that's the move dude
you Cruise in day two bro
you're the sequel dawg you cruising you
go guess what the sequels here bro
it's a sick ass call